how you doing sir I'm very good very
good and very happy to be talking to you
it is great to see you I want to start
by saying I've seen the first five
episodes and there they are fantastic
ah if I could watch the next five before
I spoke to you I would have I don't know
why didn't you they didn't give them to
me Oh five really yes so I was like I
see everyone and the others out of the
rooms are all laughing but I can't wait
to watch your subscription why do you
cannot just watch it for free all the
time
yes exactly um I there's a lot I want to
ask you about the show um first of all
how much did they because this is a
complete reboot essentially of narcos it
is no it doesn't really involve the
people before were you I mean it's
generic but were you a fan of the show
did you know what you're getting
yourself into when they pitched you I I
saw the first season because many
friends were working there Bogner is a
good friend of mine I worked with him in
Elysium so I wanted to see what they
were doing and I enjoyed it the first
season I didn't see the second one to be
honest living in Mexico is like I'm
really close to these stories like in my
everyday life so when I sit down and
want to be entertain I'd look for
something else and I didn't see season
two and then I got offered this so I
went to see season 2 and season 3 and I
was kind of impressed that they took
this bold move of yeah of basically
starting all over again you know because
they go back in time it's a different
cast different country and and it's to
me it's like a different series on a way
you know it's they're starting all over
again and this is called narcos Mexico
because even even the look of the series
is different you know even even the
approach in the in the visual language
is different I think and and I was I was
happy to get the opportunity to talk
about this this part of our history that
defines so much what we're living today
you know the eighties were very
important and
and these characters were very important
in building that structure that yeah
that corrupted structure that then fell
apart and got us into the mess we're
living I don't know how this season ends
and I don't know what the future of
narcos is because I mean it's one of
Netflix's most popular shows but when
you signed on are you allowed to say if
it was for more than one season or was
it one of these one seasons and done I
can't answer that question you know
that's why there are so many people
because half of them are lawyers and the
other secret police know I the only
thing I can say is that a lot depends on
on November 16th you know and the great
thing about these platforms about
Netflix is that they they know who's
watching you know so if if people get to
see it I'm sure they'll be not just one
more they'll be much more because the
story keeps going till today you know
it's like this field this this this
season even though it went back on time
feels more relevant than season one two
and three you know so there's a lot a
lot to talk about if we're talking about
Mexico and the relation between Mexico
and the States
but it all depends on November 16th
we'll see I'm very confident it's gonna
be real good I'm a huge hit your
character is the complete polar opposite
of Pablo Escobar he is a businessman he
is shrewd smart and doesn't he's just
not one of those it's just an
interesting character he's a businessman
and I mean I think he would be this way
if he was just selling popcorn at a
movie theater like he has just a great
brain on his shoulders can you talk
about that aspect of this character yeah
that's what interests interested me as
an actor you know the chance to do a
character that is it's not the
stereotype of the Mexican Marco you know
that you you think of the guy from a
little town that you know he's a rancher
and he lives there and he brings all his
wealth to to to the town and builds a
horrible house gigantic and fixes the
plaza and it is not that kind of
this guy is as you say a businessman a
guy that wants to belong to to an elite
and that is willing to move he lives his
hometown behind and lives in a law and
goes to what a la Jara to the big city
and and he had he had on a strategy and
and he was always one step ahead of
everyone you know he managed to do
something know people which is seat
everyone in the table people that wanted
to kill each other basically see them on
the table and and make them agree to
work together and protect each other and
and create this yeah this structure that
involves politicians police you know the
the the the military banks you know
everything you need to create a gigantic
corporation almost you know I'm curious
so it's a 10-episode season before you
start filming
how many scripts do you have and do you
know the full or not enough yeah not
enough that's that's always the fight of
an actor yeah you want to know
everything and in this case because also
it is in terms of production it is
fourth season so they have three years
on their backs that I you know like
basically the Machine has a rhythm and
you have to wait for the machine to be
ready to deliver it scripts and answers
but uh but the great thing is I had a
long conversation with Eric Newman and
and and he I asked him everything I
worried about you know at the beginning
before agreeing on on joining narcos and
he seemed to be in the in the same page
I was you know with the same interest
yes let's do something that can be
entertaining but also this entertainment
that invites people to debate to to
reflect on issues that matter you know
entertainment that celebrates also the
intelligence of audiences you know and
that is that is honest and accurate with
the specificity you know I think I think
this is something amazing about this
show that we actually are a bunch of
Mexicans
telling the story of Mexico you know and
I don't mean these just in front of the
camera behind of the camera there's two
amazing directors that are really
talented people from from from the movie
business that are doing narcos the set
designer is mexican and he we paid a lot
of attention in detail so all of that
work I think you can see it and I was
worried about that as an actor too
during a project that was gonna pay
attention to those details completely
I'm curious the making of this show what
does it like on set making a show like
this it's dealing with really serious
subject matter you have some pretty
intense violence I mean is it is it
different than other sets you've been on
or is it still just like a lot of people
having fun know that that's not the case
I did had fun with the actors because I
have to say the the ensemble of Mexican
actors the the or I would say
spanish-speaking actors because there's
people from Argentina from Spain from
Chile and and the big majority are
Mexican working with these people was
amazing and a lot of fun because it's
it's people I've been working with since
I was six years old you know and and
people I admire and I care about so from
that aspect it was fun but but the
scenes we were doing and the darkness of
the characters and the darkness of my
character which was heavy you know I
needed a tequila every night to kind of
like shake it off and and go back home
to my kids and and stop being this guy
you know completely congrats on this I'm
looking forward to that and I hope to
see you directing again soon oh me too
me too cool thank you very thank you so
much
you